Milwaukee Bucks it was a grind about
series in which the home team won them
all seven games says Terry Rozier career
playoff high in game 7 picks up right
where he left off an Eastern Conference
semifinal round
Rozier shakes Belinelli hit him with
little body stop on a dime and got the
basket comes up with a steal here George
you lay the deflection was here for
three
beep for a lot of trees in transition
that was a beautiful play by Simmons
getting Bell Nelly a wide-open shot
[Applause]
receiving end how good was that
here finds Horford gives it right back
rows here for three yes Bach for Boston
as smart working on Simmons here's Rose
here for three another one down for
Terry Rozier his fourth made
three-pointer smart wanting to push it
and meet walking up the floor and now
smart will give it up Rose ears wide
open another three is good again
but Terry Rozier there with the board
for for 22 from behind the arc
Rozier all the way
parted forum Marcus Morris draws the
double-team Rozier pull another three
and he will have another three
unconscious feeling really good getting
taunted reaches from a lot of guys that
playing with so much confident here's
Rose here yeah
[Applause]